he's a great stand-up i've done um tours
with him before i've done many shows
with him we've been in battles we fought
and uh where we scream at each other um
but you know he's been in many battles
actually he had an infamous battle with
dan cook
outside his apartment one time remember
that
[Laughter]
ladies and gentlemen he's a headliner um
he's from pittsburgh originally
and he's a dear friend and i'll know her
for i'll know him for the rest of my
life
his name is steve byrne give him a round
of applause for your time all right
welcome
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you you're welcome
okay yes um thanks for doing my podcast
yeah i i feel like i've done it already
you have yeah
yeah has he done the podcast before oh
you've talked about him so many times
i have every episode i do talk about you
a lot yes thank you yeah yeah
have i said good things so no
that's just some bad things no yeah
those things get back to me but i
yeah i know you though so i don't i know
how you are
so i don't oh how am i
well even when you said like we've had
our battles yeah okay
i think i come at things from like uh
like a pragmatic kind of like
you know i don't get my emotions
involved i think when we talk
there have been times where emotionally
i i'm confused by the decisions you've
made
but i just say you and me both yeah
i've never like when we've argued i've
never left a conversation
saying you just burned a major bridge
i don't do [ __ ] like that and i've said
that you said that to me
you said that to me as you walked to
like a corolla
and sped out of 30 miles per hour of the
comet okay
yeah my car has nothing to do with this
[ __ ] kind of business
i burn a major bridge hollywood power
player bobby lee
oh yeah
yeah he knows i love oasis
love oasis this is one of the things
that irritates me but i
again i like i don't i don't get i don't
say you burn a major bridge
i just go that's bobby his car your car
broke down or something
yeah i did your car broke down the same
corolla yes
yes thank you probably that night as you
was leaving yeah yeah
um and then i had a hyundai santa fe at
the time in my beautiful car
was it purple no it's silver oh yeah so
the reason i thought was purple i'm not
from minnesota
so i learned to i said hey you take my
car i'm going on the road
use my car while i'm going who does that
so i first of all
think about what who does a comic a
friend
whatever a friend whatever
a friend when you burn the bridge burn
it
it takes time to rebuild your lungs it
takes time to rebuild right so so i
landed my
car i get back in my car
and i go to uh play my oasis
i go where's my oasis dvds not one not
two like three oasis dvds
i i call these i go cds i go bobby
where's my oh i threw them out the
window
oh my god why are we
because i told you because you don't
listen
to my car no i know you're you are no i
broke you down and i left
my car this is who i deal with i don't
know i'm a bad guy but that's the thing
i got another one you guys ready for
another one can i defend
like it's a flyer for some sort of
[ __ ] nightclub or something you don't
like oasis we watch it
i like it now i love them now but at the
time i didn't like them i thought they
were like too poppy oh my god but i like
them now
i apologize how much money do i have 60
bucks nothing now
okay worthless yeah all right so what's
the second thing i did uh
oh you want oh well i'm sure you now i
have so many things that you've done
okay good good what what
you we'll go tit for tat good oh you
wanna get tip for that all right all
right let's go
then this guy calls me right
and he goes get it over because i was on
a sitcom called animal practice uh-huh
it got cancelled and um i was really
hurt by it
sure it was a really tough time because
um
i didn't have kalila at the time and um
that was i called you the night of
premiered
i bet you don't remember that i know
thank you i watched it i said
congratulations thank you
he doesn't make he forgets these things
yes
this next part right so i watched it
so then he calls me go sorry about
animal practice but you know i have a
show
like yeah sullivan and sons right
because i was thinking about you know um
you know writing a character with you in
it like so reoccurring and
it's going to be really cool and you
know at the time ahmed was on it
the wonderful and the multi-faceted owen
benjamin
you know what i mean just the pure
talent that he is
of course and i go yeah
you're gonna write you know you know
when somebody calls you for something
like that
you start you lay down in bed and you
start fantasizing
what it's gonna be like at the warner
brothers lot you know what it's like
rehearsing laughing with your friends
you're actually working you're on tv
with your you know it
there's nothing better right and then
three months later
i find out ken jong is doing it
did that did not did that happen you're
you're old pal
so my thing is is this okay i know why
that happened
no you think you know why it happened
and you bring this up
you're wrong oh you're tired right now
your eyes are getting graceful that's
my eyes are your eyes are grateful right
you're tired let me
it doesn't make any sense okay but we're
on a different planet right now okay and
we are so if you look at like you know
whoopi goldberg's
vagina right if she's using it
i bet it's more goldberg than whoopee
i bet it seems aggravating yeah yeah
yeah
but i'm sure if she uses it it looks
fine that's all i'm not a scientist yeah
but your labia is not a muscle
yeah dude your labia is not a muscle you
cook
you coo yeah but i know where honey
comes from
you know so we both win we both lose
where did you say honey comes from what
was your honeycomb the woods
yeah in the woods but in honeycomb yeah
honeycomb
yeah where did that come from you kook
you call me you want to call me goo gone
i do not i didn't say it
you guys edited that in there yes you
did
and we have it on [ __ ] factual files
dude okay
that's not a real thing factual style i
like that though
actual file yeah i make words up bro
isn't there a drawing that's supposed to
happen right now downstairs in the ship
lobby
can we [ __ ] get him a job that's
getting out of hand
the buffet is closed yeah ladies and
gentlemen uh
the buffet is closed well we were in
hawaii
a lot of people do look like you like
the service people
yeah a lot of filipinos work on the
cruise ships you know there's no even in
the hotel
they all just kind of have your like
bland look whoa it's not bland
yeah why did you call me bland theo i
didn't at all i feel like it's kind of
an island mahogany
i like that right but if you like worked
at a you know
in hawaii i could see it like an abc's
like if you saw me in a hotel
you know working there you'd be like
yeah that guy's weird nobody can imagine
you
working i think that's the kind of thing
that's so rude that you even say
something like that let me say something
right now okay
let me i used to work on a farm did you
know that an
ant farm no no
[Laughter]
oh my lord
that's cute that's cute man no man a
real farm man oh yeah what were you guys
growing dude honey
corn dude oh really heard of corn yeah
yeah i used to work at a farm i used to
work at a farmer's market
i used to work outside of pharmacy are
you just saying things that have no
i used to work construction i used to
wait tables i used to do a lot of
jobs did you really i was a hard worker
okay
i don't it's only when showbiz got into
my vein
that i haven't really worked one vein i
believe that part
you have one vein one way in one way out
hey
upper lip thin yeah dude my lips still
growing dude unless
lester holt has a very thin upper lip
and he's got a good kick oh yeah yeah
yeah he does have a fit
there yeah have you ever noticed that
about yourself when you look in the
mirror though huh yeah but my bottom lip
took everything yeah
here's the thing about you too
oh what about you two i hear bono's sick
is he really really no i didn't mean to
laugh
he lost his voice well you just said
here's here's the thing about youtube
yeah here it is
the edge is great that's what i was
going to say oh okay i didn't know your
[ __ ] bonnie was sick
does he just have nodes or is he like
sick
he got a tracheotomy no way
he is a traitor anything real the top
story does say bono says he doesn't know
if you two will tour again
wait but he has a trach like he actually
has a hole in his
yeah remember that that movie no country
for old yeah
this guy had that gun that would shoot
holes through doors yeah
bono got hit
he's got a hole in his throat i know but
not from that oh
not from an eric thing i think he just
has a sore throat though
sorry yeah i think he just has a sore
throat
all right guy no no country for old man
no country for bono
whoa he's got ireland i wonder if bono
gets a morning bono
[Laughter]
yeah maybe he's a little old but maybe
yeah
oh wait he did have throat cancer in
2000
ha ha
[Laughter]
you're right you're right you're right
but his second
brush went but the second brush with
mortality had nothing to do with his
throat it was a high
energy bicycle accident into his throat
it was just high energy in the throat by
a bicycle
oh man was he laying on the sidewalk i
don't know
maybe they're like little tiny bikes
health bikes yeah yeah ooh those hurt
you also go to burning man right yeah do
you go every year
i went three years in a row i didn't go
this year but the last three before that
i regretted not going this year i really
i wait i woke up every morning going why
aren't i there
and who do you go with uh first year i
kind of went by myself
and the second year i went with
my buddy michael rosenbaum and then last
year i went with my
buddy dan and uh i think i'm gonna go
next year
you know it's funny i there's such a
stigma you know on
like just people who go to burning man
in general like you know the la types
but i never if there was a you seem like
the perfect person to go to burning man
with if i ever if i could ever
think of anybody i would want to go with
you seem like nope
nope the right person she's not going
with you but i already said she is
yeah but she's
selfish yeah i am selfish and when it
comes to that dude
why can't i take your girlfriend away in
a camper
for five days what's wrong with you
hey guys guys that's my girl
okay yeah what okay
okay mr scrooge
humbug did you just call me mr scrooge
bro yeah why can't
i spend a week in a camper with your
beautiful girlfriend
what would you do what would you do out
there with her in the desert ask her
what would you do with harlow williams
we were just waltz around the playa i'd
cook good food maybe you know
hey wait you don't need to know i do
need to know man because
i know you out there they don't take
money they trade services
what's you want to get a sandwich you're
going to sell her a little [ __ ] out
what
i don't i can't sell him i know just
stop right now whoa bro
you want a sandwich you're going to sell
my little girl's [ __ ] out
his eyes are brought to you for a
[ __ ] meatball sandwich
you won this round i know i didn't i
know i didn't won this right and don't
do that dude that's a [ __ ] human
being right there man
oh i didn't see that coming let's go to
burning so two weeks ago he was playing
ontario and he goes hey do sunday i go
okay and then i never two years ago i
was there when two weeks i was at the
win
whatever the win theater
how many people that one was close to
that was six thousand total seats yeah
yeah
sold out six months so what we've
learned today is this what we learned
today is this
we've learned a lot of things today but
we've learned that um
that you know a relationship isn't a
two-way street
you know sometimes when you have two
people one's
more generous than the other
and so i think by the facts
of this trial and in this case right
it shows that i'm the one that's
being harmed i'm the one that gives
and doesn't receive what the [ __ ]
none of your listeners got that from
this show not one [ __ ] person that's
listening
yeah they did got because they're
sleepers they're my people
that you're they're my [ __ ] fans
they're my [ __ ] fans too
okay and they get me you know after you
know how to tell you this my friend i'll
tell you this my friend what
right what i can't do two weeks in
ontario
but i can sell out a weekend and those
people that come to my shelves yeah they
love me dude they love you and i'm
giving them a message
it has nothing to do with you what i'm
saying to you people
right is in a relationship one person
right is more giving sometimes than the
other person
and the other person right being an
island
an island [ __ ] right being an island
group
they suck up the energy sometimes
wow i've been to korea i've been all
right
i've been to the philippines too you
want to
talk about you want to see i beat you
korean
korea and i love
and i love the korean i love your mud
rivers and i love the fact
those are my rhythms your girlfriend my
bad baby
yeah yeah the [ __ ] rivers that you will
go ahead tell me about korea
i love what you guys i love you guys too
so much the 33
of the country that you can work with
i love the fact that here oh man you're
talking about that [ __ ] right now
i'm just would you go to the flipping
bobby what you guys get to do
you get this much yeah and then this
much goes to golf courses and the air
bases yeah
and then this goes to a guy that looks
just like you
right he owns the northern part
interesting
so enjoy whatever that is that that area
down there in the south i want to see
you guys
travel together i want to see you go to
the philippines with joe and maybe he
can go with you he would be missing
in the philippines i would see to it you
know what i would love
okay you know here's what this is what
will help me what
and i'm being real let's handcuff each
other and go to korea
in the philippines that'd be great i
swear to god that would be so [ __ ]
that'd be so funny
all right so i'm i'm i'm at work right
and uh work means the comedy store
no i was on my television network oh i'm
sorry thank you
television yeah television network and
the lady that's doing my hair
and i'm like i just i don't know why i
threw this up where were you last week
she goes oh i took a week of my favorite
festivals in las vegas so me and my
husband wine
and what kind of she's like a i guess
you know sort of doom rock
festival heavy metal okay right
i don't pay attention yeah yeah and i go
uh-huh she's like
it's funny because there was a couple of
comedians that went up
it's like gigantic and she goes oh i
just it just hit me
what there was a big festival that we
went over and did
that's what you did okay go ahead why i
didn't no in my head i forgot i did
that and so when i complimented it you
didn't even know what the [ __ ] i was
talking about
go ahead do your thing yeah
so i'm like oh i go whoa who are the
comedians and she goes
well you know i don't like dice i love
dice but sick dies he was
okay a lot of women and i go okay but
there was a girl before
that went up and i go uh-huh she was
very funny
and in my head i dies and then when she
he said
there could only be one you know and i'm
like
it's my second ex-fiance yeah i know and
i go is
it and i googled you is it her
she could that's her
right so then when i see her you know
later a couple days later
i'm doing a podcast and i go in and i go
hey interrupts the podcast i interrupted
i just walked in and i go
hey hair lady you know she was at the
vegas
and she said you you're great and you go
uh-huh
like you didn't i go thanks man yeah i
know you that was you it pissed me off
first of all you [ __ ] on it the whole
time
what you [ __ ] on it the whole time then
gave the compliment like no way it can't
be
it can't be that somebody saw eleanor
and she was good [ __ ] her i hate her
that wasn't it no i wasn't going to say
this though okay everyone say it and
you're like
i gave you a compliment i'm like you
didn't give me a compliment she did yeah
but i had that information
i know but that information you just
reiterated it to me
don't come at me i know i'm just saying
that i know you were
okay i know but can i just say this
though all right is it i
didn't have to give you that information
you could have kept it inside yeah but i
want to make you feel good i want you
make you feel good
yeah and i go and i go i'm going to make
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
feel good right [ __ ] this filthy [ __ ]
white [ __ ]
and so i throw it out there and i just
did i didn't like the response but
that's all
but you know we're good wait did it
really hurt your feelings because i
didn't mean to but we were on a podcast
so you know i'm [ __ ] okay yeah you
know i liked yeah i was kidding too
okay good but did you don't watch game
of thrones no
i don't watch that kind of stuff what do
you mean
just people fighting in the past and all
of that wait
i'm more like is that a historical
document about the past
is it something that really happened no
it's not
yeah i don't know elizabeth no it's not
that kind of stuff bro
well i'm not sure maybe i'll read up on
it a little bit no no no no look at me
no
no no i know when you know what dude i'm
tired
dude i'm tired too man what time is it i
know
i know my arms hurt too no no you're
going to do a couple more minutes yeah i
am
you're going to do a couple more minutes
while i grill you okay grow away dude i
will dude all right i am
i'm tired of your [ __ ] wake up with the
king honest dude's [ __ ] making
burgers over here yeah yeah i'm tired of
your [ __ ] right not good
because you like to you know what you
like to do you like to distract me
i do yeah [ __ ] word games dude no i
do not yeah you do
no yeah you do techniques don't do that
again either what is that take this away
from
[Applause]
what i'm saying is daylight [ __ ]
savings time in my [ __ ] right now
i'm wearing glasses yeah but you know
you look nice tonight no don't don't do
that don't
do that right now don't do that right
now no what i'm saying to you is this
okay this is this okay is that what i
say that a lot right yeah i'm sorry
no don't be apologize it's not a bad
thing all right is
it's a great show i think you'd really
like it
it's like i in terms of pop culture i
think there's not a better show out
there
what tiger belly no i mean game of
thrones
oh yeah i haven't seen it i know you
have it you see
wow there's a groundhog i don't see what
are you doing i know
i'm no i'm not gonna let him do it he's
not going to groundhog yeah you have a
little different i know what you're
doing
defense mechanisms that you do right and
then you try to divert me and i go oh
yeah okay i guess
it's like jedi mind tricks it doesn't
work with me
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] i didn't do it i
don't see that
yeah i'm not accusing you of doing
anything dude oh my god i don't know
you're not a dummy you're a bright young
puppy you watch it
oh what are these prescription pills on
the table it's [ __ ] for my a panic
attack yeah well
yeah yeah it's actually high blood
pressure yeah
yeah i do dude i'm about to stroke out
back off the t
what is that uh drug that they're always
putting in uh asian people's food
yeah let's back off the msg daddy
you out there [ __ ] putting speakers
in your car and [ __ ]
sipping on soy sauce dude back off wow
that's actually good advice you should
scale back on i'm gonna scale back on
the soy sauce
okay wow all right now we're getting
somewhere all right but i listened
right you gave me a suggestion i
listened yeah i'm sorry no don't
apologize because there's something to
apologize for
all right you're going to watch game of
thrones okay i'll watch it
every episode no yeah bro
uh yes okay oh yeah yeah
shouldn't have said okay yeah yeah you
said okay and that's a promise how many
episodes are there
seven seasons [ __ ] man
ten seasons to ten seasons in an episode
10 episodes
and what's it about it's about the past
the past about the past fighting
i got [ __ ] [ __ ] to do man no no
you're going to do it
i'll watch some of it i'm so sensitive
about that though i just don't get it
yeah bobby i know you you play on the um
on the funny all the time like you play
on the funny but i it's got to offend
you when
because you're you're a shock comic like
you you do like to say what's on your
mind
you do don't [ __ ] give me that look
[ __ ] there's a bunch of words you
said before this [ __ ] show started
edit yeah yeah we do don't we do we not
do we not have to edit a book okay okay
i want to say this okay do we not have
to edit a bunch of words
you want to talk about you want to talk
about [ __ ] that was said before we even
started this thing
no i will tell you something right now i
don't want it i know but i'm going to
tell you something right now dude all
right
i say [ __ ] up things like that so that
i don't say it on the podcast so i can
just get it out
okay i'm purging it all right got it
all right god man yeah
is that my camera yeah yeah i also want
to
i would also want to say to you that um
the first time we ever met
yeah no no i i know i know you heard
some things i said
this is the only reason i'm here it is
because your little [ __ ] tiger belly
crew
are being are being misinformed yeah
what do they call you people the tiger
bellies sleepers slept
have been lied to yeah yeah what is the
lie go ahead what the [ __ ]
i saw this little clip do the rounds
yeah you're sitting there in your little
[ __ ] office with your sicker fans
i'm michael bisping he just ignored me
yeah he didn't get a picture with me or
anything that's not how it went down
at all shame on you no first of all
michael i want to say this
stand up because it doesn't look any
different to sitting down
you son of a [ __ ] it's like this you
son of a [ __ ] it's like you leaned
forward
i was very funny very funny but let me
see
go ahead go ahead i'll tell you the way
it went down give your version
yeah and i'll give mine okay for the
what are they called again sleepers
sleepers okay so um
every once in a while because you know
joe rogan is a stand-up he's
a long-time friend i've known him for 20
years
25 years um love him great guy but um so
a lot of
you know i'm a huge ufc fan so who's
that little guy from sacramento
that i like you're my favorite right
you're our father man you nice guy we
hugged this and that
but then when i saw bisping michael you
for the first time there
i literally was struck i was just like
oh [ __ ] that's michael bisping
right and i tried to come up to you and
i said
you were very nice but i said hey man
i'm a big fan and you were you know
because when i walked i was at um the
the grocery store and people come up to
me and go
oh you're very funny and i you want to
be cordial right
but i also if that person that said hi
to me was josh groban
right right okay and i blew him off
right i bet that josh groban would
probably be a little mad so
he was at the comedy store where first
of all i don't know who josh robin is
okay so i've got zero context of what
you're saying an opportunity
is
so when michael's business was there he
said very nice
but he kind of just walked away and i
wanted some you know me
did you ask for the photo no i didn't
really okay but he did walk away though
already it's and here's the reality yeah
so and i'm not when i say this
yeah by the way yeah by the way massive
fan hence why i'm here hence why i drove
up from [ __ ] orange county
thank you did an audition and i waited
for three and a half hours my vision was
at 5
30. i was half asleep half an hour ago
okay
yeah yeah i'm just pounding some coffee
now i'm drinking this shite try and stay
awake and i'm very happy to be here
you're a
hilarious comedian i've never met you
before i don't okay
hold on i know you're getting to the
point yeah yeah
the long suffering mrs bisping that's at
home
god bless her she doesn't get out very
often you know she's got three kids i
travel a lot i took her out
we went out for a nice dinner and went
to go watch some comics and
a lot of the time i'm not trying to say
that i'm a [ __ ] big deal or anything
like that yeah
but a lot of time you stop and you take
pictures and this and that and then
after a while you've got to say okay
because i'm here with my wife and i've
done about 10 pictures in a row well
she's standing there like a [ __ ] lump
of cheese
right doing nothing so then after that
i'm like okay all right all right babe
let's go in and then you after that i
said i'm not sorry mate
we're done picture time is over
right you should start doing this now
let me say something right so
when you or not fair sorry if i didn't
put a random stranger before my wife
um i i i i'm so sorry you know i know
you're the great
one the great bobby lee and the comedy
store is your house
and you're totally right it is your
house but we've never met
and that's the mother of my children
right you're you know what and
the way it's okay i accept your apology
get your [ __ ] english
it's fine it's fine [ __ ] pause out of
my face right you you weren't denied
you weren't denied all right he was
devastated though he called me
immediately after
he ran to the parking lot and he was
like you can't
you won't believe what happened i just
got turned down
well for one right but no but can i say
say this please can i say this
please go ahead you did give me a photo
i did yes
afterwards i remember i was talking
about that yes
with diaz and i walked up because when
you were talking to diaz
you know that then i seized my
opportunity and we took the photo you
know what i
was just talking out of my ass right
just talking [ __ ] or whatever
yeah i'm not thinking that you're ever
gonna [ __ ] hear it
it's okay we're not gonna say i do it
all the time if i was held accountable
for every piece of dog [ __ ] that came
out of my mouth yeah
i'd probably be in prison yeah you know
or or you know excommunicated from
whoever i know
and you know i want to say this too is
is that because never let the truth get
in the way of a good story
right you know go out i feel like that's
right
write that down write it down i've never
heard it before
chinese proverb what is you with your
asians right now man what do you mean
with the yeah
i mean it's a [ __ ] chinese brother
i could never let that get in the way
that's not like george st pierre
that fight right was crazy don't don't
don't
let's not talk about that you're okay i
don't want to talk about you but here's
what i do want to talk about okay
well i want to talk about you but i have
a couple of other questions i want a
favor and my favorite is the next time
you do
a gigantic show like a theater show
whenever you're like stadium
i would love these where's my dude
[Laughter]
it's right here there's this multi
camera
this multi i have offered i have offered
every show that i've had i said bobby
just
walk on stage you don't have to ask you
don't have to tell anybody
just walk on and what do you say every
time
okay no you don't does he say that
he doesn't reply he never replies you're
a piece of [ __ ]
i know and that's okay yeah yes
that's my camera which one's my camera
is it the one behind me or the one
directly in front look in the mirror
you look at that camera look at this one
so what you tell me
you tell me bobby sorry tell me
all right so so what i'm saying to you
right now people okay listen to me right
now okay tell me
and you have the facts you've listened
to this podcast from beginning to end
and be
all right be honest and know in your
hearts no in your heart
listen to the facts and don't do it for
fun right you know it goes
on his side going on his side would only
be for fun
but you know he's a [ __ ] liar he's a
liar this [ __ ]
runs in there all over the world
gigantic theaters
right i've asked for [ __ ] some
promotional help oh
about being on like your podcast [ __ ]
kidding me i promoted you didn't give me
nothing and then
last week here i have a netflix special
can you can i do tiger but like oh yeah
yeah i'll clear monday for you you [ __ ]
thank you
because i love you thank you
you don't deserve it sometimes it's
trendy you don't deserve it sometimes
all right anyway anyway what do we have
time oh that was an
hour can we get through this unhelpful
advice
yeah oh my god how come you never
watched the cartoon
oh god i know how did you miss out on
that he was
too busy is that good yes
gilbert look at me it's that good that
i'm missing out
i want all right you know what i'll
watch that [ __ ] tonight if i'm not
mesmerized
if it's not live all during right the
cartoon the next day he's singing all
the songs around the house
yeah but you already going to tell you
what i think i'm going to tell you
what i think it's about okay okay
there's a man
yes he's some sort of curse okay
right and he turned into a buffalo
whatever it might be yeah
okay go buffalo all right
it's a buffalo and then there's like a
salt shaker
[Music]
a salt shaker right this is what i'm
saying
a salt shaker a light bulb there's a soy
sauce
right it's japanese
yeah you know and a um
old old-timey trash cans right they come
alive
yeah they start because what i assume
that
he was a king and those were all his
like
compatriots or whatever and there's some
sort of curse they turned into
salt shakers he turned into a goat right
and they're bombed they're [ __ ]
living
because you can't live like a [ __ ]
soul shaker yeah i mean you're just
shaking you're walking around you know
man people know you're when you're
coming you know
[Laughter]
there's larry i suck at hide and seek
yeah right right right and then you know
the goat meets there's a lady okay a
girl comes in into town
she's fresh she's fresh into town right
yeah yeah she prays
right she comes to the you know the
castle she meets this goat
and she's scared at first right she's
like
ah man this is a good creature i don't
want to be around it
you know and then they fall in love and
something happens at the end there's a
bunch of songs
okay the thousands of songs he sings
yeah yeah and then at the end
something happens where he turns back
into human and they fall in love
do i have the gist i feel like you've
watched it and you're playing it off
like you did it
[Laughter]
ask my brother i've never seen any of
that [ __ ] [ __ ]
bro why do you hate me just [ __ ]
accuse me
you broke your ipad you just accused me
of [ __ ]
um treason against against my [ __ ]
speech
my um uh race not my race my gender oh
oh god the male gender i've never had
don't ever accuse me of piercing looking
for money okay over disney ever [ __ ]
tell me
so you might do i have the chest i just
yes you're pretty [ __ ] good that's
amazing yeah
yeah i kind of just give more movies and
see i know i want to see and um
let's just bury the hatchet with
everything okay i don't ever want to say
it again
okay in other podcasts yeah we're ending
it now whatever
because there's a lot of purity and
goodness yeah that comes from you
yeah i mean i haven't talked about you
at all but you're the one that talks
about me but
so when you're saying we we bury the
hatchet it you bear that
you bear it you did it okay let me
rephrase this is the screen cap of this
oh let me rephrase that
you better hatch it and this is what it
is okay yes
i you could have just let it go with
that i could have said
we bury the hatchet right yeah and then
we could have just
moved on to the next thing right yeah
but then you had to add in
right you bury it i don't you bury the
hatchet i know whatever that's what it
sounds like okay but
you bury the hatchet where where where
where have you ever been where you're
like
word on the street is burns talking [ __ ]
on like where is that
no because you have more of a rat pack
style that is never happened
but i don't you're like sebastian
menosco in that way you guys have
like a real like huh no you do i just
keep to myself like right back
like the red pack like a team yeah
they're they don't you know me you don't
rat your friends out you know like the
mafia stuff
right he has those things and i'm the
guy that dies the five minutes
right i get stabbed a thousand times by
a pencil okay
i mean just in the first five minutes of
the movie that's how yeah because i'm a
talker
yeah i'm a coward right but yeah you
know
you know i'm okay yeah but let's just
bury it now
i'll bury the hatchet okay since you
didn't you don't have a hatchet
right i'll bury the hatchet yeah i'll
bear for life okay and then you and i
can move on
yes right but you know watch it
[ __ ] watch it dude i'm not afraid
dude you know
you know i love you though that's why
you're here
we you know i love you listen you have
you do know that correct
that's what you're saying for the fact
that he does get especially triggered by
you because i think he has a deeper love
for you than he has for compared to
other people
because when he had you guys had that
weird thing at the comedy story